did you guys have like school festivals
in your high school like like how they
have in japan i think that's only a
japanese high school thing isn't it bro
in japan they make a school look so fun
and
british school is the most depressing
[ __ ] oh no i like to do anything
you guys are here telling your high
school stories i don't remember it [ __ ]
i remember [ __ ] off from high school
all i remember is bad bad things see
people always say that i actually had a
i think i'm like the one percent that
actually had a good time in high school
i think i had a
um i think i had a good i liked my
friend group a lot yeah
i had those four of us we were all
really close but yeah stuff that
happened in school was just always awful
like what i don't know i got so much i
got in so many fights
oh yeah i mean i guess you yeah yeah
yeah like there was one time as well
this is one story i remember and this
like drove my blood like through the
roof dude yeah so there's a day in the
uk i don't know if you do this in
australia where like the kids who are
coming into high school get like two
days
before like in like june before
september starts yeah where they get to
just come and see the school
yeah my little brother was coming up
right oh like an orientation yeah yeah
yeah so i was like showing my little
brother around and one of the
the guys just the bullies just comes up
to me whilst i'm talking to my little
brother
just slaps me in the face what just
slaps me in the face
and i this is already i'd already been
in like multiple fights at this point
right
um and me and i i get slapped and i'm
like all right it's go time
are you saying hands are coming up like
you slapped me first i'm not gonna get
in [ __ ] now if i beat you
yeah yeah i started fighting him and
then in front of your little brother
this is so [ __ ] weird to me yeah like
in what world is this just literally
does this thing just happen literally
just slaps me and then i'm like
wait there
because because i was like thinking like
i got to show my little brother i'm not
a [ __ ]
right yeah he's my little brother he
looks up to me right like i gotta show
her that like
i'm not a [ __ ] right because if he sees
we get slapped i'm like oh sorry sorry
yeah he's gonna think wow
my big brother's kind of a wimp what's
up with that
this just sounds almost sounds like a
[ __ ] in-betweeners episode it is
because then it turned into a [ __ ]
tournament arc where then all his
friends the next day were like oh well
we want to turn now
jesus christ now there's one time and
this is probably the one where i felt
most bad is that
this guy came up to me he's like kind of
chubby and i thought yeah what are you
doing
what are you doing man right what's up
with this he pushes me once and i was
like all right
fine i grab his head and just [ __ ]
knee him
and bear in mind okay i do not do not
condone violence
in any sense but but i watched it i was
such an
angry 13 year old because i was getting
bullied since like you were 13 when you
did this
yeah what the [ __ ] you weren't even in
high school you were like middle school
maybe like no i'm not like 13 like 15 14
maybe maybe 50
still 15 yeah and this guy didn't i've
never had a problem with this guy i
didn't realize why he was doing this to
me but i think i
pissed off one of his friends and then
he you know trying to act big i don't
think he actually wanted the fight he
was just pushing me around
but i was like [ __ ] it anyway so i did
that and he just dropped and i was like
oh no
oh no i'm going to be an alien i'm
committed i'm going to be in a lot of
trouble
i don't even think i did it that hard i
just thought i saw it in a movie once it
looked really [ __ ] cool
i saw bruce lee doing once i could do it
sir who gets hurt by getting kneed in
the face
he was slightly smaller so he pushed me
and then i think he was going think i
was gonna go for a push and i just went
like douche
and then he just like dropped for like
five seconds and i was like oh [ __ ] are
you okay
and he was like yeah yeah i'm fine and i
think he was so embarrassed that he
didn't tell anyone
right and then he came in the next day
two black eyes
wait wait how did you get two black how
wide is your knee
so we came with two black eyes didn't
tell anyone but all my friends knew what
happened
no one said anything it was like that
one week where i had like three fights
right no one did anything for me the
rest of my school life it was great
everyone everyone was nice to me
you had more fights in that one week
than i think i have my entire life i
think you get more fights in that one
week than anything this is like fight
club because
in my school it was it wasn't about like
getting into fights it was about
who did you know like if you're cool
with x person if you call it
i don't know if it's because it's like a
small town thing like my and like the
it was such a small town thing yeah like
the teachers often like forgave the
shitty behavior because
more often than not all the teachers
were friends with the kid's parents
right so
yeah it was kind of a thing of like oh
don't do it again don't do it again
so you need someone in the face every
single time it was like don't do it
again
don't do it again you know that wasn't
like a proper punishment right now
i mean you know it's it is what it is
right i don't really care now i've i
dealt with it myself did you go to a
boys school
no oh okay so maybe that's the aspect of
it right because i feel that
boys will be more willing to get into
fights if it's a co-ed school
because they're trying to like impress
the girls i never wanted to i just
wanted to play my game to be like yeah
but it just seems like [ __ ]
fight club honestly man it was [ __ ]
awful
i joke about it but i remember hating it
when i was i probably [ __ ] hate it
too for that
yeah yeah and then i remember there was
like one guy who would like
he he didn't want to fight me he didn't
want to fight me because he i think he
knew that he'd get hurt
so he would just oh like i said he would
spit on me and anytime i try to like
fight him he'd just run away
so what can i do right it's like that
one [ __ ] who like kites amazingly
i was like come to me
his torn game's like on point yeah yeah
yeah he just fights you and he's just
kidding me
then he would run to an area with
teachers right and i can't [ __ ] like
punch him from a teacher he'd make a
[ __ ] amazing adc main man
this is why i'm a jungler that's what
i've brought in man
me fight don't think i'm like no i
wouldn't okay if any 13 year old 14 or
kids don't fight it's not a good
solution
yeah i mean i i was just lucky that i
was freakishly strong for a 12
13 year old as well that helped a lot
yeah um i don't know because
for me i've always gone through life
being like okay
and physical like interaction is always
like my last choice
yeah yeah yeah i i have that now but as
a kid i felt like it was my only
you weren't the hard way yeah i mean i'm
i'm glad that i was angry as a kid
because now i have like
zero anger at all right i never get
angry about [ __ ] now and i'm so glad
that i just got that [ __ ] out
you know i don't know if that's how
anger works i don't know if this is
science i'm not sure about that it's not
but i feel like because i've dealt with
so much anger in in my past right i've
been able to like really
like i don't know it's like you feel
it's like you filled your anger quota
for of life
so i think so i'm running right now i
genuinely think i have to like i don't
know i don't know i just got out of the
system now i get like mildly frustrated
at things like any good british person
would but
i never get angry at things